more now on the Wall Street plunge and
why it is continuing Deirdre Bolton
joins us good evening Deirdre good
evening Chris on Wall Street we saw the
fifth day of 500-plus a point intraday
swings for the Dow the fifth day of
heavy selling and it is now down 10
percent from its recent record high
which means it is officially in a
correction so this sustained selling
does make some investors anxious but to
others they see this return of
volatility as long overdue we had almost
an entire decade of stocks moving higher
year-on-year strategist telling me the
US economy is solid American
corporations are delivering on earnings
and sales we have 17-year low
unemployment we have wage growth for the
first time in almost a decade and
corporate America is beating estimates
in fact in this last quarter almost 80%
of the time but the higher highs and the
lower lows that is just part of the
investing landscape thanks to computer
guided programs so humans right trading
programs to kick in automatically when
markets hit certain levels but in only
one part of the market and I'm just
looking at hedge funds quantitative
funds are responsible for almost 30
percent of all US stock trades and that
is double the amount of about a decade
ago so the bottom line here is that
there are more machines in the mix they
process in greater volume with greater
speed than humans and the result is
higher volatility now in today's session
the bond market also found had 10-year
Treasury yields up to four year highs
and that affects consumers because all
borrowing gets more expensive so
mortgage rates they are already ticking
up 3.9 5% is what we saw in January this
week 4.3 2% so obviously still
historically low levels but if consumers
want to borrow money to buy a house or a
car it is going to cost more and for
corporations borrowing also more
expensive I know the House and the
Senate are voting on that sweeping
budget deal that would stave off another
shutdown but it also increases federal
expenditure spending of course over the
next two years and some strategist
saying this idea of another 300 billion
dollars of spending and how we're going
to pay for
is another part of the market anxiety
Chris back to you other than that
everything is great dude thank you